I'll give you the first rule of
Entrepreneurship that I've learned use
what you have and a lot more people have
pain a lot more people have anger a lot
more people have shame and if you can
use that as your gas in the beginning
you'll eventually get to a point where
you can get out of that Loop and then
find something that you are really
passionate about but if you can't tie
your shoes you can't lift the weight you
can't send the DM then you have to start
with whatever you have for me it was
hatred of my current existence I hated
being an entrepreneur I hated being a
wannabe I hated being one of those
people who like talked about all the
things they were going to do and didn't
do anything I hated living the life that
my dad wanted me to live I was his
sometimes your parents dreams have to
die in order for yours to live the idea
that my father had of me as his son that
image had to die in order for the image
of myself that I wanted to be to live